這支股票開盤開很高
結果5分鐘後跌破軍架線
之後就再也沒上去
那我們來看他盤中
各位看他走到這個地方是不是賣壓很沉重
對吧各位看一下
他的賣盤
都只有掛一張
因為我們看的時候我想說
這無人背呀
沒有什麼賣呀 那我就不要賣
對吧 而且買盤那麼多
理論上這支股票應該不會這麼弱
但是呢 我不知道各位買股票的習慣是
買喔 你是習慣買這裡 還是買這裡
我不知道
看這邊啊
所以如果假設你要買股票,你是掛615
對,對,你是掛615還是掛615
假設你現在要買這支股票
很急就掛615
但是幾乎大部分的散戶都是掛這一邊
比如掛610或掛690
因為他想買便宜嘛
這是很合理的
這是很合理
而且同時你會看到賣盤
沒什麼賣牙
但是我跟各位講
只要主力或者是大戶他想賣
他就是直接掛這裡
賣
他不會掛這裡
掛在那邊說讓散戶來接
讓散戶來追
不會
所以我要跟各位講的這個重點
在後面
這支股票那麼強 買單只有223張 最近無黨只有223張
這邊最近無黨賣壓有1300張 也就是說漲停有一堆人掛在那邊等著賣
好,對吧
後來拉漲停去擋這樣
那我跟各位講
這個是主力常用的手法
主力會故意在這個漲停或者是漲停前一檔
擺很多賣單
告訴你不用追了
我很多人沒別
你不用
這一種常見的情況就是
這些是
主力自己擺在那裡
當他要做上去的時候
他就把這裡的單子抽掉
然後這邊同時就去追
把這些籌碼
同時就把它收起來
然後把這裡的籌碼
收掉
把這裡的賣單收掉
那就會變成這樣
收完以後他就全部轉掛自家單買進
這個非常常見
這種非常常見
那這五檔呢
各位要留意看的是
這五檔的總單數跟這五檔的總單數
這兩個的
數量差很多
也就是說
賣壓這邊比較大
對吧
這邊有16000張
這邊有9500張要買
這邊有16000張要賣
賣單比較大
而且各位要特別留意的是
整數關卡
比如說18塊
19塊或18塊半
這種整數關卡
通常的賣單或買單
都會卡在那個地方
各位要仔細留意一下
如果這兩個數字有很明顯的差異
那你要特別留意
假設以這個地方
我們要先確認的是
這支股票現在正在走多頭趨勢
這個地方賣壓比較重
那你反而要小心
這個是主力在騙你
聽得懂
你要留意的是這一點
價差左右如果數量差很大的時候
你要特別留意
像這一檔也是一樣
賣有560買呢
有35張
這個就是標準的
60塊整數關卡跟前一檔
跟前一檔
這個就是標準的主力壓價格
就是壓在這種位置
字幕by索兰娅